alright let's talk a little bit about
how you actually manipulate data so
you've got an array of information but
you need to do something with it in
JavaScript we have something called
methods which you should have look up on
the Mozilla developer Network methods
are built into the language an example
of methods would be split if you do
something and you split it it takes
whatever it is and it breaks up into a
bunch of little pieces in an array you
don't have to write that function that's
already built in into the language you
can use a lot of these methods and put
together your own functions if you have
a specific way that you want to
manipulate data but it's not already
built in as a method you can create that
function in your JavaScript the main
point of this video isn't to memorize
what methods and functions are I just
want you to know that there is a way
that you can manipulate data and that
you should really be checking if there's
a method that already does what you want
to do